today's topic we got a video from jimmy
kimmel all right
i hope you had a relaxing labor day it
was not a fun labor day weekend coveted
wise the number of new cases is up more
than 300 percent from a year ago dr
fauci said that if hospitals get any
more overcrowded they're going to have
to make some very tough choices about
who gets an icu bet that choice doesn't
seem so tough to me vaccinated person
having a heart attack yes come right on
in we'll take care of you unvaccinated
guy who gobbled horse goo rest in peace
wheezy
i mean
we still got a lot of
pandemics out there i don't know what
happened when late night tv shows just
became
the mouthpiece for mainstream media but
it's frightening when people get up on
public platforms and like media
personalities
and
newscasters you know you see these
people very like public even public
officials have said or said some
iteration of this you have to sit back
and think what do you think this does
for public discourse when you say well
if that's your stance then you deserve
to die by the side of the street what do
you think that does when you want to say
something to that person's benefit and
you'd be like guys this is what you need
to do it's going to be good for you do
you think they're ever going to listen
to you you just thought you know go die
by the side of the stream give a [ __ ]
we're going to give a bit so like
you know
we've become so tribal about this whole
incident that you know you see joe rogan
and you see him getting covered hello
friends so i got back from the road
saturday night
feeling very weary i had a headache and
i just felt just run down and
just to be cautious
i separated from my family slept in a
different part of the house
and throughout the night i got fevers
and sweats and i knew what was going on
so
i got up in the morning got tested
and turns out i got covered and people
were like [ __ ] great and we were just
hoping they're salivating at the
opportunity that he might die after all
the stuff that he said on his podcast
we've gotten so extreme with this stuff
that even mainstream news just getting
out of here saying oh horse d warmer joe
roga takes like they're spreading fake
news and they don't even care why
because it appeals to their tribalistic
instincts yeah
like we are
pulling at extremes so hard with this
thing and then afterwards we're
wondering why the other side doesn't
trust or they're not participating you
have never fostered an environment
where people can really come together
and feel like they can trust each other
the moment these disagreements extend
themselves rather than try to bridge
that gap people just pull on these
extremes
our media is failing us in ways i can't
explain again you're looking at two
people are vaccinated and i'm looking at
this dialogue and i'm like what you
[ __ ] are crazy this vaccine
passport nonsense this dialogue that
you're having nonsense and i thought
it's so funny that he started his little
monologue by mentioning darth vader big
ass fraud as well
lying to congress about the fact that
these people funded the research that
potentially led to this whole pandemic
there's a lot to be said about the way
this conversation is going it's crazy to
watch for me on the outside people will
be out here talking about oh
lives are precious
all this other stuff oh is that your
decision die you know when it comes to
topics like these often times they get
deranked because we even mention co or
or or this pandemic so yeah if you want
to help support us like and comment
right it helps us boost us up an
algorithm it gets these kind of topics
more to the forefront and that's how you
guys can help us beat the algorithm in
ways yeah it's interesting hearing
the left really expose itself a lot
during this dialogue you think about the
unvaccinated
per capita
minorities are very over represented and
i did an extensive video on why you know
minorities have issues with the health
care system and the lack of trust and
goes to extend even to this vaccine
there's a lot of hesitancy there due to
history right
and it's interesting hearing this man
out here crying jimmy kimmel loves to
cry on camera cries for minorities
christ for people suffering oh i
remember that
oh
he loves his tears he loves his tears
and here you have that same shared
history contributing to the problem
today in regards to vaccine hesitancy
and all of a sudden his compassion for
people who
sometimes maybe they're victims of
misinformation sometimes maybe they're
just victims of history
or sometimes maybe they're victims of
their own ignorance it could be a
plethora of things
but rather than approach it from a
compassionate standpoint it's no go die
right black lives matter when it's
expedient but black lives don't matter
when it comes to this vaccine business
so it's interesting watching this
dialogue unfold you know there's a lot
of hypocrisy involved and a lot of um a
lot of ignorance on the part of people
who think they're in the know and on the
right side of history
turns out they don't know their history
so it's disappointing
well
if you don't take the vaccine fine
that's your choice
but if you end up going to the hospital
and you get coveted then die
let's say i grant you
that you're correct your stance is the
right one
and that these people are completely in
the wrong right
they are being negligent
is it really going to be people's stance
that because folks are negligent they
don't deserve treatment
really
is that what we're going to do that's
what we're gonna do
let's do it
you don't wanna do it so if you get in
the dui
and you crash
don't deserve to be helped nope
if you're handling a firearm and you
shoot yourself
don't deserve to be helped just die nope
that's you really yeah and look you may
not have sympathy for these people
understand but we're really trying to
say that health care shouldn't be
afforded to these people they shouldn't
be helped you just let them die let them
die now if he dies he dies
there's an extra layer of this where
people say no no we're not saying that
but
if the hospital beds are overloaded and
we gotta choose between uh vaccinated
people and unvaccinated people as we
have to triage where they'll
make sure the vaccine listen
you know when you got to make tough
decisions about who gets health care and
who gets to live versus who doesn't if
your criteria is whether they're
vaccinated or not
sorry but that's a poor poor criteria
why is it
because i think there's a lot of things
you should run down through before you
choose whether they should be vaccinated
or not
well health concerns is this person
really healthy are they chronically sick
should i save an 80 year old vaccinated
person versus a 20 year old who's
unvaccinated
you know these are like much more
important questions than vaccine versus
not and listen you know granted if i
gave you the most perfect scenario and
it's like 20 year old versus 20 year old
one's vaccinated what's not there's only
one icu bed okay maybe in that scenario
i could understand but that's not the
way this talk is going whatsoever
it's really not
at the end i think i think it's it's a
stupid way to look at this issue i
understand people feel very strongly
about this they think it's a very
serious issue but now we've gone to a
point in public discourse remember
initially it's like everyone do what we
can to save old folks right sacrifice
which is a part of it right it's the
compassionate thing to do and then i
don't like your choices well [ __ ] you
damn you know what it's just such a
crazy trade like we hate how many like
is this such a crazy man there's people
at the beginning who are just like man
[ __ ] old people but you know what the
thing is it's crazy
when they got when [ __ ] were
righteous like that yeah when it rises
like that
you just gotta give it a little bit of
time so for the thing to like you know
see if it was lasting
if it wasn't the values a little bit
yeah that's the value the hardest i saw
this meme the other day it was great
meme is you know what's the hardest
thing about uh the two weeks yeah to
flatten the curve yeah the first 18
months
that's it's all good to be right because
i told you the last two weeks
but now it's been 18 months
so now
you see [ __ ] being tired and
being like you know what enough with
this kill him and him yeah and him yeah
and it's coming from the it's coming
from a person that maybe he is
vaccinated or not i don't care but if we
vacuum yeah
you have to understand why like certain
people are vaccinated as well right
certain people like him
he gets vaccinated if [ __ ] goes south
he has the means to help himself you
understand what i'm saying let's say he
has a vaccine and [ __ ] goes out he could
go to a hospital
private care as a matter of fact he
don't even need to go to a hospital the
hospital can come to him he has the
funds and the means for that so when you
take your advices from people
from the the
stars the music industry entertainment
industry that got the funds and it's not
gonna it's not really gonna affect them
it's like whenever back in the pandemic
people were saying all these big ass
stars were saying yeah stay home help
the people i was just thinking to myself
it's easy for you to stay home when you
got a pool a basketball court a tennis
court
seven cars and made and made the bank
account to stay home uh a cinema inside
joe a bowling alley it's easy for you to
say that you got the means and it's not
gonna stay home it's not the same thing
as you that is yeah you got five kids
but i'm not i'm talking about yeah you
got five kids but you got three nannies
it's not the same thing if you stay home
then a single mother with three kids but
you know what she didn't make her
choices so oops too bad for her or a
single dad oh well you shoulda you
should have chose choose better if
things go south they have much more
means than you to get help they get
private help so be careful who you
yeah
get that guy you're not not gonna get
hit well you're gonna bypass all of that
[ __ ] and get premium help so it's easy
for you to say that yeah easy even i'm
saying because i recognize that i have i
am also in a position of privilege where
i i could
i could tell people yeah get this get
that but i also have you know a certain
amount of money that i could bypass
certain things
so be careful you take those messages
from as well jimmy kimmel i mean he's
been a sellout for a hot minute so it's
not too surprising but
i didn't expect this low
you didn't
like you you know
you saw this and you from the crier who
talks about people yeah go die no but
you know what priest that's your thing
you expect the worst out of everybody
that's that's your thing right i i i was
with you i started a video and i'm like
oh there's this thing that happened
you're surprised like yeah i do know
what i do that's every video that but i
do you're right you're absolutely right
cause i like your thing i lost faith in
a lot of [ __ ] but you look at me like
i'm crazy though no no it's not that
you're crazy it's just like you got a
lot of [ __ ] wit you like you you you
see [ __ ] sometimes you speak [ __ ] i
don't see oftentimes you see [ __ ] that i
don't see and see this guy that was
crying and you saw the tears and you
were i saw you see the theaters and you
were like
really
you know what i mean
so it's just because of that but you're
absolutely a hundred percent on that
i see the worst in i expect the worst
out of everybody is it because i'm dead
inside is it because i've seen [ __ ] is
it because i don't
know i don't know what it is i don't
know
they got rubbed by gun pointed by the
cartel on a roadblock yeah that's what
they did that's what the cards they'll
be doing but that's what the card
they'll be doing
you've seen the news it's out yet
you made me laugh though uh
that's pretty much the extent of what i
got you know
i do expect the worst out of everybody
yeah literally the start of every video
30 first 30 seconds i played clip and
i'm like yeah
shocking you know what shocking i'll do
better what's shocking is that your shot
i'll do better it's okay i'll do better
funny i'll do better uh but that's
pretty much all of my thoughts on this
video it's pretty much all you got on
this video
don't go the opposite don't be a drama
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below
uh that's it man hope you guys enjoyed
it
[Music]
foreign